foreign
I've got three things that I personally
never travel without I've tried to
travel without them and that's why I've
actually learned that I don't want to
travel without these things because they
add value to my travel experience the
first one which we'll put up on the
screen Jordan will throw it up here in a
second is a earthing match so we did a
whole episode about earthing we brought
Clint Ober on and the earthing mat that
I use from earthing.com not a sponsor
obviously advertisements still suck
we're actually sitting on some earthing
Mass right now I'll model this one for
you so I'm standing on one yeah yeah so
you're standing on one I have a seated
one I packed the one the full queen size
one yeah that I'll just put on a
mattress and it doesn't take up that
much space no it doesn't you could
travel with a a simple seated one or the
one that Ryan's standing on right now
which is about twice the size of of this
or in the picture you have up here that
is the full map it just goes over top of
the bed and the first thing I do if an
Airbnb Hotel room or someone's guest
bedroom is I pull the sheets off the bed
and I put the earthing mat on the bed
and that allows me especially if I've
been flying somewhere grounding
immediately after flying really helps
reset my circadian rhythm because Ryan I
couldn't tell you how many times we used
to travel without this and you get to a
new time zone new place and all of a
sudden you're up till 2 A.M dude
miserable it really is no the earthing
mat is is pretty awesome it's funny how
again like whether it's Placebo or not
like I sleep better when I'm when I'm
grounding at night for sure I'm gonna
give you guys a real good life hack
you use your earthing mat while
listening to Santa Baby by Eartha Kitt
you don't even know oh my God the second
thing I always bring with me and I
forgot this a few trips ago and I was
really frustrated with myself and it is
my sleep mask the Sleep Master sleep
mask it's a good one I've mentioned this
on the podcast several times before
people always ask me about it we'll put
a link to both of these in the show
notes the earthing mat and the Sleep
Master sleep mask I hate it's the most
ugly thing I own because it's blue this
weird shiny satin blue teal maybe yeah
so you can see it it's a sleep mask and
so every night I sleep with a sleep mask
especially when I'm traveling because
you don't have control over the lights
in the room sometimes like there's a
flashing alarm in the room where there's
a there's something peering in you you
put you in a room where there's a bright
light coming in through the window or
whatever and you just have to deal with
it well this blocks that out it makes
traveling so much more enjoyable also if
I'm on a plane I can just throw that on
real quick and take a quick nap it's a
great sleep mask the third thing I bring
on uh any travel is the pair of red
underwear Jordan I love how Malcolm
brought that up earlier I know right
so I have a confession the red underwear
you saw in the documentary minimalism
which you can still watch now it's no
longer on Netflix we've removed it from
Netflix you can check it out at
minimalismfilm.com there are six hours
of bonus interviews there as well that
didn't make the film 20 other videos I
believe all there at minimalismfilm.com
that red underwear that you saw in there
it's no longer red oh it's blue you
hypocrite
he changed sides oh he's Democrat that's
right it was a big political statement
I just uh well I went to when that pair
went bad I went to go reorder a new pair
and they didn't have any so I I just
needed one pair of underwear that was
different from the other underwear so I
wear black underwear every day except I
wear I own one pair of blue underwear
and anytime I'm wearing that Bex look
somebody says oh it must be laundry day
yep and that was the same I learned that
from being on the road if I'm wearing
the blue underwear I better go do some
laundry because I'm out of all of my
other underwear but it also acts as a
separating barrier so my clean underwear
are on top of the red underwear and my
dirty underwear go underneath the red
underwear and this separates the clean
and the dirty underwear so I'm not
accidentally wearing dirty underwear two
days in a row although if I did no one
would know uh one time we were on tour I
wore the same t-shirt to nine different
events so it was nine days in a row Ryan
and I were doing event after event after
event and it was probably six different
events in nine days but I wore the same
t-shirt and guess what no one noticed at
all
so those are the three things that I've
tried to travel without and I have
failed because they add value to my
travel and traveling with nothing I
don't want to travel like Jack Reacher
although I aspire to travel like that he
has nothing but what fits on his person
or in his pockets but for me a simple
travel bag with a few things that add
value to my travel experience they don't
get in the way of the travel experience
they don't create clutter for the travel
experience and that's really we've been
talking about for the last two and a
half hours on this private podcast
episode is intentional travel bringing
the things with us that serve the travel
omitting letting go of the things that
get in the way of experiencing the place
that we're going to jack reach your hack
wear cargo pants
hey I want to get to that level how how
bad would you feel just traveling doing
all the things just nothing but what you
have on yeah it'd be awesome I think we
were about to probably travels like that
Leo babata yeah he probably does uh so
I've been falfing a lot frisbee golfing
or disc golfing depending on where
you're at in the country they call it
all sorts of things
um I carry I used to carry just two
discs now I carry three discs
um but my buddy he started off exposed
yeah he did 11 then seven and and I
think now he's down to like three or
four but uh uh Mariah shows up with one
desk and she like destroys us she's very
good at frisbee golf
um but it's funny because like the last
time uh him and I went he because he
usually has a backpack with all his
discs in it and this last time he was
like oh I decided to try it out like you
do and just bring a few discs and the
whole time he's like this is amazing
this is so nice to not have to carry a
backpack
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free